as I said before we are fortunate to
have just an extraordinary pan
and what I'd like to do is although this
wasn't in the program I think would be
appropriate for each of us to just
introduce ourselves very briefly one
sentence introduction what you've been
doing and what you're interested in I
mean library broad foundation were
engaged in education reform scientific
and medical research John Surma CEO of
the united states steel corporation on
behalf of the pittsburgh business
community welcome senator and this
distinguished group is our headquarter
city we employ 5,000 people here we're
celebrating our 107 year of making steel
in Pittsburgh Jim Jones I'm the
president CEO of the Institute for 21st
century energy and we're working on
comprehensive energy solutions for our
nation and also for the international
sector I'm sorry I'm going to General
Jim Jones also was a four-star general
and the supreme Allied commander of NATO
so he's being a little must go ahead I'm
federico pena i'm a partner in a private
equity fund in denver called vestar
Capital Partners prior that I was
Secretary of Transportation and
Secretary of Energy under President
Clinton and mayor of Denver for eight
years and very happy to be here in
Pittsburgh to share my thoughts with
this very distinguished panel Mel
Brainard from Brookings a place in
Washington that tries to generate a lot
of good ideas on competitiveness ha's
and delighted to have candidates that
might take them up and delighted to be
here in Pittsburgh vinod khosla
religious believer and investor in
technology and innovation and a Carnegie
Mellon and a Carnegie Mellon alumni
there you go all right don't want to
miss that
I'm Rick Wagner CEO of General Motors
that we make cars and trucks
I'm Susan hi I'm Susan Hockfield I'm the
president of the Massachusetts Institute
of Technology a sister institution to
Carnegie Mellon and along with Carnegie
Mellon we produced the innovations and
the innovators for the nation's future
I'm Steve Case i'm a co-founder of
america online help get the internet
part of everyday life i'm also start a
new company called revolution trying to
transform industries like health care
but my real claim to fame as i went to
high school with barack obama in hawaii
this is so good morning i'm jeff canada
i'm the president of the Harlem
Children's Zone we're working in a 97
block area with 10,000 children making
sure all of those children succeed good
morning my name is Andy Stern I'm the
president of the Service Employees Union
the largest union in north america and i
represent the janitors here at carnegie
mellon i want to shout out to brenda and
cynthia our shop stewards here at
carnegie mellon I'm Susan Castillo on
the state superintendent of Oregon and I
am thrilled to be here uh in a
conversation that makes that direct link
between education and prosperity in our
country i'm harold varmus i'm president
of amor o sloan-kettering Cancer Center
in New York I run a laboratory that
works on cancer genes and on the former
director of the National Institutes of
Health during the Clinton administration
well it be as you can see we've got an
extraordinary group and I want to
apologize to the audience in advance
that we're probably not going to get to
every good idea that's represented on
this panel but hopefully we can touch on
a few and what I wanted to do I thought
the best way for us to organize the
conversation was to start with some
building blocks of competitiveness that
I've been discussing and and studying
over the last several weeks and
certainly during the course of this
campaign everybody right now is thinking
about gas prices everybody is concerned
about not only the impact on individual
pocketbooks but also the overall impact
on our economy and our environment so I
thought that that would be a good place
to start it strikes me that if we don't
get our energy policy right that it is
going to be very difficult for us to
maintain our competitiveness and our
long long term standard of living and so
I thought I'd start with you records you
make cars and trucks and obviously
you've been impacted profoundly by the
energy markets I know that you know
during the course of this campaign I
visited the plant in janesville and
Wisconsin wonderful workers state of the
art plant it was producing large SUV's
and and you had to make I know a painful
choice the workers there are obviously
in a extraordinarily difficult spot the
question I guess is how how do we shape
our energy future in a way that allows
GM to remain competitive that keeps some
of the best workers in the world on
their jobs that's generating profits for
the company and shareholders and is also
remaining a key anchor for our community
how are you seeing this develop right
now Thank You senator I think the from
our sector we start from history which
globally we've relied about ninety-five
percent on oil is the source of energy
to power vehicles and it's clear from
the trends and oil prices in the demand
for oil that we now need to move to a
phase where we're going to diversify the
sources of energy that are used in our
sector and others as well from our
perspective that offers advantages
including more stability and energy
prices energy security and address
addresses emissions issues as well so
this is a I think an initiative that's
really worth taking on and from our
perspective there's there's a handful of
things that are either ongoing or will
be ongoing soon that I think we'll put
the u.s. in a much more competitive
position and certainly help help help
our sector and our our company in our
workforce let me start by saying the
first thing we need to do is stretch
the use of the oil that we do have and
so things like improved internal
combustion engines and the application
of hybrid systems are important and are
ramping up quickly in the US will be
offering eight different hybrid models
different price ranges in the US market
by the end of this year and we do expect
that will continue to use oil for a long
time but a very importantly alternatives
to oil I think first and foremost would
be biofuels and we have in our company
invested in a couple of cellulosic
ethanol producers and are very bullish
on the prospect of doing that and it
turns out by virtue of history and our
global footprint the US manufacturers
are the global leaders in the ability to
apply biofuels and you you have
commented on this yourself but if we
really want to move and diversify our
oil sources away from oil using biofuels
is the way we can do it fastest down the
road there are very exciting
technologies and some not too far down
the road battery technology particularly
lithium-ion technology is moving at a
very rapid rate and we've targeted to
build an exciting car and extended range
electric vehicle called a Chevy Volt by
the end of 2010 and that's something
going to be be the beginning of a new
era a different kind of automobile and a
different kind of energy source and then
beyond that we're very optimistic about
the prospects for hydrogen and hydrogen
fuel cells and we and other
manufacturers have test fleets going
there but what do we need to do to
realize this obviously it's going to be
a cooperative effort between government
industry energy providers and I think
things like support for basic R&D for
infrastructure for consumers ability to
adopt the new technologies these are all
going to help accelerate these so I'm
convinced if we go out with the right
kind of leadership in cooperation we can
move in a depressive pace away from our
our virtual complete reliance on oil but
I think it's fair to say we need to get
on that task and accelerated now let me
just ask you a quick follow one of the
challenges for you are a US automakers
is you are in this process of transition
but in the meantime
the market is changing rapidly US
automakers have been losing money and in
some cases market share and so the
question is assuming I'm president let's
say what what what what what what would
be the the one or two things that the
federal government can do most
constructively to make certain that they
in this race against time for the US
automakers that you are able to make
this pivot as quickly as possible they
it it is a matter of getting enough
research money in place what role should
the federal government play of relative
to the private sector in terms of moving
this process along as quickly as
possible obviously all of you recognize
that the markets change so you have
every incentive to do so but you may
need some bridges to help get there we
do a senator I think the first thing is
with clarity of vision as to where we're
going support for basic research in the
battery biofuels and fuel cell areas are
going to be critical because those are
all still just developing and other
countries have supported research in
those areas and so in some cases like
batteries the u.s. is actually behind
Japan or maybe even in some cases Korea
so we have we have some work to do there
but we've got a lot of smart people
working on it in the US so that would be
very important I think the second thing
to keep in mind is the application of
these technologies particularly at early
phase is pretty expensive right and so
we do have incentives for consumers as
you know to buy hybrids and I think
we're going to need to provide some
support for me to make these new
technologies affordable and then finally
converting our traditional manufacturing
base to a alternative energy
manufacturing base does require capital
and I would say one of the biggest
issues the US industry faces that we
have relatively weak balance sheets do a
lot of things post retiree health care
costs and stuff and so a support in
birding the manufacturing base would
also be helpful good now dr. Hockfield
you are at one of the greatest research
institutions in the world I know that
you've actually helped to launch an MIT
wide initiative to spur innovation and
research and alternative energy so how
where are the areas that you see most
promise and how does a research
institution like MIT interact with both
the federal government as well as the
private sector in order to get this
research out the door and actually
working on behalf of American industry
yeah it is a great question a question
and answer I would say that's on the
lips of almost everyone at MIT I did
launch an energy initiative just about
two years ago and it plays directly from
Rick Wagner's comments we see a lot of
opportunity a lot of real possibility
this is technology we can mount but the
technology alone is not going to be
sufficient so we're also very interested
in kind of new policies that that Rick
referred to I think what's critical is
this two-part approach we need to work
as fast as we can to improve our current
technologies because we're going to be
using oil coal and oil nuclear for the
for the near future that doesn't mean
that we're going to use those
technologies they stand today we've got
to improve them but the second piece has
to be working very rapidly on a range of
alternatives biofuels solar wind tides
because at this point we don't know
where to place our bets we don't know
which of these technologies is really
going to be planted it was really going
to play out and so doing this two-part
approach is critical and what's critical
to make that happen is of course
research investments our research
investments in energy don't reflect an
innovation economy at all if you look at
the health sciences industry we're
between private industry and government
we're putting something on the order of
90 billion dollars a year in research in
energy if we look at the combination of
industry and government investments in
new energy technologies it's about 6
billion dollar
a year so we have not positioned our
nature for the our nation for the future
we think there's a lot of opportunity
now I have to add to this that at a
place like MIT and I'm sure the same is
here at Carnegie Mellon our secret
weapon in this energy challenge is our
students they are wildly enthusiastic
about it because they see the potential
and what we have to give to them is a
vision of a future a bright clean energy
future that we're actually funding our
way to to arrive at and I can tell you
that if we provide the modest incentives
that they're going to be able to work in
this field which many of our students
want to they're going to be there with
their brainpower with their enthusiasm
they want to invent the future and
they'll do it in the realm of energy
work now we've been talking about it
obviously in economic terms but there's
a major environmental imperative to deal
with this issue climate change at this
point I think we've got a broad
consensus that it's something that we're
going to have to tackle and one of the
things that one of the centerpieces of
my energy policy is a cap-and-trade
system which essentially creates a price
for carbon emissions generates not only
a set of changed incentives in the
marketplace but also generates billions
of dollars much of which will have to be
given back to consumers because they may
have to otherwise would have to absorb
rising costs for electricity but also
generates about 15 billion dollars a
year over the course of a decade that we
can reinvest in solar wind biodiesel
basic research research on new batteries
and so forth and the nice thing about a
cap-and-trade system as well as the way
that I think we have to design our
research efforts is as you said not
knowing what's going to be the home run
what what's going to work out but
spreading that money widely including as
you point out some areas like coal and
nuclear where that may not be the
optimal energy source of the future but
if we can figure out ways to use coal
productively if we can figure out a way
to store nuclear waste safely it has to
be part of our energy mix and I want to
just jump to you vinodh because you were
talking about some of the exciting
advances that you're saying that denote
by the way is I think uniquely placed in
thinking about these issues this is a
co-founder of Sun Microsystems but is
now maybe the largest but certainly one
of the largest venture capital investors
in renewable and clean energies and the
last time we talked you were doing a
huge amount of work on cellulosic
ethanol what Rick talked about but it
sounds like you're also starting to
figure out some things around around
carbon emissions and conversion that may
be exciting as well it talked to me both
specifically about some of the most
promising areas that you're seeing but
also talked about how we get good ideas
into the marketplace and actually into
applications so that consumers are
starting to benefit in businesses are
starting to to profit from some of these
inventors Sega I'm senator thank you I'm
very optimistic that we can have a
radical revolution with stable policy
innovation just like it made
long-distance calls free in this country
in ten years can make alternative energy
cheaper than traditional old energy and
increase our competitiveness it can save
us five hundred billion dollars a year
because we can produce fuel from
non-food sources that is green at a
dollar a gallon within the decade we can
produce solar utility-scale power that's
about the price of natural gas-based
power almost now
so and in new technologies for carbon
sequestration are doing radical things
in new approaches so I'm very very
optimistic that some of these things
will work out just to give you a couple
of examples there's a company that's
figured out that instead of the millions
of years it takes biomass returning to
crude they can do it in a few hours
that's a startling example company
that's figured out the best way to do
carbon sequestration is not to try and
capture gaseous carbon dioxide but turn
it into a solid and use it in the built
environment they produced cement from
old carbon dioxide emissions without
changing and building new plants so so
much innovations going on and the best
part of it because America is the
innovation capital of America this
company i mentioned that stunning
biomass into crude moved from europe to
the u.s. a company that turns the
smokestacks and flue gases of steel
melts into ethanol move from New Zealand
here the solar energy company i
mentioned move from Australia to America
all this is happening because we have
innovation captain we have to keep that
leadership now let me let me ask you a
question the what what do you see the
barriers to what do you consider the
barriers to innovation that are still
out there right now and if you're if you
were setting federal policy what do you
think would be the most effective
approach to ensuring that these exciting
innovations are moving rapidly that
there's some that would argue that you
know you've got venture capitalists like
yourself you're putting money out there
the markets working and Washington
doesn't really have to do much there
others who would suggest that and and I
tend to fall into this camp that
absolutely the private sector is going
to be carrying
most of the load but on something as
important as our energy policy we need
the kind of leadership that John F
Kennedy showed when he said the America
was going to the moon that we're going
to have to make some federal investments
and then we've got to put the full
weight of our government behind these
efforts do you want to weigh in on on
how how you see that playing up
surprisingly the biggest obstacle to
innovation and this change is people
believing it can happen what we need is
a vision of where we want to be in 10
and 20 years and have stable policy the
biggest impediment to investment is
policy that changes with the latest
women fashion so we can have stable
policy and a long-term view an
investment in fundamental university
research and development because when
she capitalists can do the private
investments I think we'll be there far
faster and faster for cheaper than
anybody else imagines so an example of
stability would be I know in when it
comes to wind power for example right
now they're pretty dependent on the tax
credit that is about to lapse in
December and as a consequence you don't
end up seeing investments being made
because people don't have enough
certainty in terms of what the market is
going to look like and what their price
structures are going to be 5-10 years
out and these are fairly substantial
capital outlays so they've got it
they've gotta wait until they've got
some sense of whether or not this
stuff's going to be renewed absolutely
we need a long-term view whether its
wind credits or stable solar policy you
know Solar Credits extended in two-year
increments you can't build a
utility-scale plant in two years right
and whatever the numbers and I suspect
we will need less over time than we
think in subsidies and incentives we
will need a commitment to renewable
portfolio standard a renewable fuel
standard and that would that stable
policy in a clear statement of vision
the more importantly convincing Wall
Street will not be spaced weighed by the
special interests of the old energy
industry
but general Jones you're now working in
the energy sector with the Chamber of
Commerce you're seeing the impact of
skyrocketing energy costs on all sorts
of businesses all across America so I'm
interested in your perspective as
somebody who's in touch with not just
the big industrial users and but also
people who are just struggling with
rising costs every day what
opportunities you see out there what
concerns do you hear out there and if
you could also touch on the national
security elements of energy as somebody
who served this country at the highest
levels in our military I know that
you've thought deeply about this and
have some concerns in terms of how it
can impact our national security well
thank you so it's great honor to be here
to touch on a subject that's really one
of the defining issues of this very
young century and I think we're at a
moment the historical moment in time
where the nation is at a crossroads and
needs to decide which path is going to
follow particularly on energy because
it's going to define us I think in in
the in this still-young century our
energy appetite is going to increase in
this country by about thirty percent
over the next 15 or 20 years the global
appetites going to increase about the
fifty to sixty percent so it's not just
about oil and gas although that seems to
be what precipitates the the current
discussions and that's okay because it's
a real big problem but it really does
fuel our competitiveness and it affects
everything from national security to
family security and in ways that are
profound and and simply have to be
addressed one of the things that I think
we're going to have to come to grips
with is that while everybody agrees that
something has to be done and signs up to
exciting plans we we always hear the
word nimby which is the not in my
backyard syndrome everybody's for a
solution but as long as it doesn't
affect them there's another syndrome out
there called banana which is replacing
nimby in my book and it's build
absolutely nothing anywhere near
anything and if we don't if we don't
come if we don't come to grips with that
that this is a this is about us this is
about who we are as Americans this is
about our leadership in the in the world
in terms of energy the United States
cannot be seen as being on the wrong
side of this issue we have to be on the
right side and we have not been on the
right side of this for for quite some
time dr rockville pointed out the
government spending less now on energy
research than we did in nineteen seventy
we spend on energy research in this come
in this country about three days
equivalent to what we pay for oil
imports and that simply has got to stop
and and there are things out there that
that can help us get there the public
opinion is extremely important it drives
change in our democracy and it's about
our competitiveness in the future and
it's about our not only our national
leadership that our global leadership
and it's about a long-term solution
let's make no mistake about it it's got
to be that we have to commit to this and
we have to understand that it is a
long-term solution and the good news is
that there are there is potential out
there now as to the question of national
security i touched on the fact that its
national security but it's it's also
family security but let me talk about
national security for just a second I
got into energy in my my military career
late my military career on a very narrow
axis that's the axis of the fact that
terrorist organizations have made it a
stated goal to impede our our way of
life of developed world not just the
United States but particularly the
United States by impeding the access and
flow of energy and so it's been a
declared target just last week
terrorists execute
a very sophisticated raid 60 miles out
into the Gulf of into the off the coast
of Nigeria and the Gulf of Guinea on an
oil platform 60 miles out in open sea
and there are many many more instances
of those kinds of things happening that
aren't necessarily page one but it is it
is what really focused me and got me
thinking about it and started suggesting
to organizations like the north atlantic
treaty organization that the world not
just the United States has to be more
proactive in this secondly the the other
thing that got caught my attention is
about two-thirds of our of oil and gas
is in foreign hands and in government
hands which is to say that nationalized
companies nationalized assets give an
economic and political leverage a
political weapon actually that will
affect the course of public dialogue and
of course our own security with regard
to energy so we have to we have to free
ourselves of that of that of that weight
in that influence and we can do that
through diversity and you've heard some
of that already you'll hear more later
you can do it through efficiency you can
do it through affordability because that
gets back to the family aspect of things
whatever we do has to be affordable for
our families and you can do it through
technology and you can do it probably a
lot quicker than we think and the
cornerstone of that is going to be
leadership at the national level our
next president has my view has to make
this a top priority or Congress has to
come together on this in a bipartisan
way and we simply have to we have to
commit to a longer-term strategy instead
of short-term solutions the next
Secretary of Energy in my opinion should
be an inner part of the president's
national security council it is it is
that that important they will define who
we are it is important for our families
and it's important for our nation Oh
deserve thank you but I want to shift to
a second pillar of competitiveness and
that's an education but before we do
does anybody else want to chime in on
any of the energy issues that have been
been raised good job Thank You senator
just a brief comment on energy and cap
and trade I think it's important to
recognize as you go through that process
of cap-and-trade if that's where we go
that in a large imposition of the carbon
price in a globally competitive sector
like ours and steel because forty
percent of steel trades internationally
and of course we're energy intensive if
not done thoughtfully it could have the
perverse results of suppressing domestic
production with with difficult problems
for employments for national security
potentially for middle-class jobs and
shifting that production to
international locations that aren't
bound by any climate regime and
typically they would have far higher per
unit emissions of co2 so that we would
have the worst possible result of damage
to a naturally important and competitive
sector and higher global emissions so I
would just let you consider that there
are some sectors that maybe look at a
little differently than others and and
making sure that traded products meet
the same emission standards that we've
achieved which are among the lowest in
the world good no I think that's
absolutely critical they just to amplify
that if you set up a cap-and-trade
system there's a cost tool and sometimes
people just throw out the word
cap-and-trade will solve global warming
and pretend that it's going to be easy
they're going to be expenses involved in
terms of retrofitting and improving
efficiency in plants and and figuring
out sequestration technology and if we
are doing everything we need to do but
China is not or Brazil is not and you're
having to compete against steel makers
in those countries and they are able to
send and steal at a much lower unit cost
not only because of wage differentials
but also because of these environmental
standards then we're going to lose jobs
and the environment is not going to be
improved because it turns out you can't
build a wall up
into the stratosphere to cordon off
global warming effects so that now we
have an opportunity because of the next
round the successor to Kyoto that the
next president will almost immediately
have to enter into and you know the key
is going to be to have a set of
negotiations that includes what were
once considered developing countries but
at this point our full-blown competitors
of the United States if China India
other carbon emitter czar not involved
in that negotiation and held to similar
standards then we're going to have some
problems and it's probably not going to
be as effective as it needs to be so if
you make a very important point anybody
else soon as you want yeah I just want
to make something explicit that we're
actually all talking about we're talking
about potentially the next cycle of
America's innovation economy this is an
invention post-world war two invention
of the United States it is absolutely
phenomenal so you do federal investments
in research in research universities
that has provided the most extraordinary
educational environment on the face of
the earth and that those research
dollars fund someone with getting Chang
to do innovative you know not
particularly directed research that
produces a new battery a123 which is one
of the contestants to be the battery in
the bowl and those technologies come out
of our universities into the hands of
people like Vinod Khosla and you know
which lead to new industries lots of job
growth and you know the nation the
nation gets better and stronger and you
know we see this often as you know we
think about the energy crisis is
something where we just have to cut back
we've got to cut back their costs and
costs and costs but it's actually the
other way around this is a place where
we invest it will increase our
competitive advantage and make us
economically more successful so you know
I take John's point very seriously and
so however we designed the policies
however you know as we accelerate the
technologies we've got to be sure and I
have confidence that we can do this that
this will be good for everyone
absolutely
sure right there on this comment which
is a good one on international
competitiveness as I've thought about
the cap and trade issue in particular
remember of us cap it has occurred to me
that the US has a responsibility to lead
in this area but we want to do this in a
way that actually grows our economy
doesn't retard the growth and if we do
that we can actually be a model for
these countries that you cited which are
growing and in some sense competitors
but if we can if we can show that we can
put in a system that changes our energy
policy and does it in a way that
actually improves our economic prospects
I'm completely confident that China and
India and Brazil will will will say
that's a good idea we'd like to do that
too because I haven't seen anything in
this country's which they say gee we
want to pollute a lot I think right what
they need is a vision and I think we
have a chance to provide well absolutely
I mean look at the that they still are
burdened by enormous poverty and it's
not realistic for us to expect them to
retard their growth in ways that we have
not been willing to do so it's important
for us to lead we still have a much
larger carbon footprint per capita than
any of these countries but you're
absolutely right that if we make the
investment if the innovation is
happening here then we're going to be
able to franchise to license
technologies to other countries they're
going to be willing to adopt it and and
these actually can be markets for some
of the green technologies that are
developed and coal being the classic
example if if China is building a
coal-fired plant every week but they
also recognize you can't breathe in
Beijing they've got every interest if V
nodes the investees develop the kinds of
technology he's talking about they've
got every incentive to adopt that as
quickly as possible if I might add a
quick comment given as an investor in
Google I can tell you many more Google's
would be created in the energy space and
its innovation is the area where
America has a competitive advantage I
cited three of the four companies moved
to America and I think we have to press
our advantage in innovation denote by
the way after the panel will give tips
on the next Google will have a little
sidebar conversation that Federico
senator in addition to all the brilliant
ideas that have been discussed that in
this panel I think the most important
thing is federal leadership by
establishing a goal we're now importing
sixty percent of our oil from other
countries in the 1970s when we first
embarked on this venture we're only
important about thirty five percent of
our oil no president has said this is
our goal now you have said the reason
I'm supporting you is that by 2030 you
want to see a thirty-five percent
reduction in the importation of oil I
operate best when I have a goal so the
American people know that you've had
your establishment ago you have
strategies and we can show marketable
progress so that by 2015 that sixty
percent import number comes down to
fifty five percent then to fifty percent
then the American people all of us and
people around this panel will know we're
making progress and it's working so I
think that's so probably the most
important thing let's get a goal let's
be serious about it let's start marching
down the path we're not going to do it
overnight we can take some time doing it
but let's begin the effort the I'm going
to go to Harold and then Stephen then
we're going to ship to education Thank
You senator those of us out in the
outfield like to have a chance to pitch
in here too it was very briefly but some
of bricks remarks prompt me to say
something about this notion of
competitiveness and another side of the
formula that we're addressing here we
know that we're not alone and looking
for alternative energy sources at China
Indian every country in the world is
groping with the same problem just as
we're all worrying about about aging and
about food supplies and about water and
about many other things that don't know
national boundaries and these issues
which are funded in research and in
technology development
offer an incredible opportunity not just
for Republicans to work with Democrats
but for people in different countries
scientists who speak the same language
to work together to solve common
problems state I think that Google came
up a couple times I think it's worth
looking at the history of the internet
and the role of government played with
DARPA on the ARPANET really making the
initial basic research investment and
put that in place and then the market
really took over a lot of
entrepreneurial companies reformed and
that's really what made the internet
part every deal I think there's some
some lessons to be learned from from
that approach I also would would note
that some of these ideas can really be
leveraged and taken to a whole nother
level if we focus on a particular place
and really try to make that sort of a
model home and demonstrate a particular
community how this could work and
actually may seem parochial because
we're both from Hawaii but there's a lot
interesting things happening there
Hawaii has unusually high cost of
gasoline because it is so isolated but
also benefits from having a yew spear
barely contained geography and there are
a lot of opportunities to try to take a
place like that and really try to make
it you know energy self-sufficient and
take some of the land at the
agricultural land used to grow sugar or
grow pineapples now growing weeds and
instead have it grow energy there's
initiative like Hawaii bioenergy and
write the notes also involved in in
others and there's a lot of hope because
of that a level of excitement and
investment but it requires a goal that
requires that the government really
saying this is a national priority and
then the private sector and
entrepreneurial innovation really taken
hold but I think it's a great point and
just one example of setting a goal and
then government being involved in
setting up at least the foundations that
is the issue of our electrical grid
which is a huge capital outlay very
difficult for any investor even vinodh
or steve case to say we're going to go
build an electricity grid but if we have
a smart grid the the
the ramifications of that for being able
to get wind energy from South Dakota to
a user in Pittsburgh our capacity for a
plug in the bolt to be plugged in and
not just get energy but also put energy
back into the system is extraordinary
and we have not made a serious
investment it has national security and
homeland security implications as well
that's an example of something that the
federal government in the same way that
it helped to develop our postal service
or the internet or the interstate
highway system or the Intercontinental
railroad that those are the kinds of
areas where because it's a common pool
it's something that everybody has to use
in order for it all to work government
has to be involved all right little bit
none of this is going to work unless we
get a lot of really smart people and
it's not just the inventors at the top
in a knowledge-based economy we need an
innovation from the bottom as well and
Susan you're somebody who is on the
ground as a state superintendent in
Oregon so you're seeing on a day-to-day
basis the challenges and struggles we
have in making sure that every one of
our children are trained for this new
knowledge economy you're struggling with
an achievement gap where we still see
low-income minority children performing
at levels that just aren't acceptable if
we want to stay competitive what what
are you saying in terms of the major
obstacles for children achieving their
full potential and and how can not only
the federal government but all of us in
these various sectors help in improving
our education sector Thank You senator
for the question I listening to this
conversation I guess at the heart of our
challenges today in public education is
that we are trying to go somewhere we
have never been before and that is
every child to higher levels of skill
and knowledge so that we can address the
many issues that are before us not only
in our country but across this plant the
planet and I think that it requires us
to think about what we do in public
education in a very different way we
really that paradigm shift that needs to
happen to keep up with the changing the
quick changes in technology our global
economy the knowledge-based economy and
and knowing that if we don't get every
child to higher levels of skill and
knowledge we are setting them up for
doom in the future and setting up our
country for that same fate so it is we
have wonderful pockets of success
schools that are leading the way and how
we bring all children to high levels of
knowledge and skill our challenge is
taking that to scale so that it happens
in every classroom in our state in my
state every classroom in this country
and thinking about how we then create a
system that better enables us to take
that work to scale and as we peel back
all of the various levels of challenges
that we have in public education I think
we get back to the heart of what school
is all about the teaching and the
learning and helping to support our
teachers to have a knowledge and skill
to address all of the many challenges
and this higher goal is higher
aspiration for all children and helping
them get the support and the tools they
need and we have not been stepping up
enough to address that so I asked for
your help I know we need a partnership
with the states and the federal
government working together in how we
accomplish that better every every
teacher needs help in knowing how to you
know create a multicultural learning
environment we could be successful with
our growing diversity and every student
that walks in the door knowing how to
comfortably and proficiently use
technology our children walk in the door
and they walk in with all of this
knowledge and access to the Internet and
often times are walking into classrooms
where they don't have access to any of
that in their learning we absolutely
have to address that in every single
classroom in America and we can I think
we also have to get back to one of the
core i would say essential elements to
when we take a look at where success is
happening in schools and in classrooms
really comes back to that very
passionate belief by the educators
involved that every child can learn
every child can reach high levels of
achievement and when we approach our
work that way and we get the support and
help that we need to move forward on
that very passionate belief we see
success happen for all children so we
know it can happen it is happening our
challenge is how do we take that success
to scale in every single school in every
single classroom you know I want I want
you to chime in on this of the you've
embarked on an enormous philanthropic
effort to improve the education system
working with Bill Gates and Roy Romer
and others you know I've talked about
some of the key components that I think
need to happen teaching has to be a
central focus how are we expanding a
well trained teacher in core that is
committed to the highest levels of
achievement you've been seeing some
great experiments but Susan makes a good
point in every city you can find one or
two schools that are doing great work
even in the poorest toughest to teach
neighborhoods but the problem is we
never seem to be able to expand it so
that it so that it's system wide it
becomes the exception that proves the
rule what are you saying that could get
us to change that pattern and what role
do you think the federal government
should play in this effort given that we
still have a patchwork of local school
districts
with with different approaches and local
controls been a strong tradition in the
united states senator after running to
fortune 500 companies eight years ago I
decided spend my time at her foundation
to look at K through 12 education and we
like to think back to 40 years ago when
we were number one in the world and high
school graduation rates we're now number
21 if we want to regain our competitive
position world maintain our standard of
living I'm convinced we have to revamp
public education and I'll be brief there
are six things I think we have to do to
revamp our public schools first more
learning time our kids are short changed
American students only get two thirds of
the academic hours to get in other
countries we have a hundred and eighty
days school year more or less six hours
a day two thirds academics that gets you
to 720 hours of academics a year in
other countries Korea they go to school
225 days a year Italy 210 days a year
and after school in other countries they
have a second shift they do homework our
kids spend five to seven hours a day
watching TV and video games we clearly
need a longer school day in a longer
school year second we need better
teaching countries like Finland
Singapore Canada where two teachers from
the top of their college graduates we
don't we did he give teaching the
teaching profession more respect we need
to offer financial incentives to
teachers and schools that do superior
jobs we need to have differential pay
for math and science teachers and also
for teachers who teaching it was
challenging schools third we need
stronger American standards children
need to know English math science and
history regardless of their from
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania pensacola
pensacola or portland
why should kids instead of Washington
gets to our two years of math while Ohio
they get four years so we need stronger
national standards and I believe a
national curriculum at least in math and
science fourth I think we need public
school choice different students the
different education options to make
smarter choices parents have to have
usable data so they can determine which
public school or public charter school
your children are go to fifth we need
21st century vocational and technical
education we want to love our children
to go to college but by the ether ninth
grade many children do not see college
is a viable option so what do they do
they drop out because they don't see the
point of finishing high school if we
offer them 21st century vocational
education so they have better access to
a good job whether it's an auto
mechanics electrical work plumbing
utility workers and alike things that
can't be outsourced and the last thing I
want to mention as I do believe that
governors and big-city mayor's have to
be given the authority and held be held
accountable for how they educate kids in
their states and cities I think the next
president of United States has to tackle
a number of competitiveness is
challenges with the economy national
security education energy health care we
need an education system far different
from what we have if we're to get
succeed and this is in a democratic or
republican issue in American issued
affects all of us and we have to be
party blind when it comes to educating
our kids so some of those things are the
things I believe we have to look at it's
a terrific summer now the
Jeffrey when we look at the problems
facing our education system you've got
an overarching problem of all schools
raising their standards I'm even in
schools that we consider good
middle-class schools we still have to
pick up our game but we've got a
particular problem when it comes to
inner-city schools and obviously the
work you've done with the Harlem
Children's Zone is designed to recognize
that not only do we have to work
internally to improve the schools but we
also have to make sure that all the
elements that go into a child being
successful being able to focus being
able to perform all those things have to
be attended to at once as opposed to in
piecemeal fashion you want to talk a
little bit about what you're saying with
your efforts in Harlem and and what are
the biggest impediments to closing that
achievement gap and taking up the the
performance of kids in those communities
well let me just start off by saying eli
has laid out I think a formula that
really makes a lot of sense and what's
happening in certain parts of America in
Harlem is certainly one of those places
where jobs have long ago sort of
disappeared for a population of people
and it's just not Harlem I mean this is
happening all over America I would dare
say you'll go all over Pennsylvania you
find those places where jobs disappeared
those communities are really in trouble
you get drugs you get crime you get
young people filled with despair and
nobody has an answer about what to do
and this has been going on look this was
going on when I was a kid I'm 56 the
same schools that were failing students
when I was a child are still failing
today and it seems to be no sense of
crisis about this at all look it would
be one thing if this was one or two
schools we're talking hundreds and
thousands of schools all over America
these places if this was if American
education was a business these would not
be profit centers these would be costing
us we are losing money
with spending all of this money on jails
and prisons and locking these kids up
these kids aren't paying taxes they
aren't contributing to their society not
raising their children I think this is a
huge crisis what we decided to do in
Harlem was do a public-private
partnership we got private dollars from
folks like Eli and the philanthropic
business my own our Board Chair Stan
Druckenmiller came in and match with
public dollars and we said we're going
to fix this we are not going to accept
any excuses if you come to work for me
you have to improve the outcome of those
children all you have to go find another
job and when I came in to run and open
our schools what I said to our
Chancellor this this was now five years
ago I said to I said the Chancellor
Klein in the mayor bloomberg I said look
I'm gonna open schools I didn't want to
go into the school business running
schools it's the toughest business I
think there is an America and I try to
avoid that but there was no avoiding
because my kids weren't working so we
had to go into school so I said okay
fine i'ma going to schools but I stood
up in front of the mirror and the
Chancellor in my community and I said if
in five years I don't run better schools
then the school surrounding my kids I'm
gonna fire myself I told the mayor that
I told the chance of that and then when
everybody left i looked at my stamp like
I'm a fire my step myself but I'm going
to be the last one out the door all of
y'all want to be fired before me so this
is an effort where I think you know I
believe that our country cannot remain a
great nation if we allow significant
numbers of our children to perish simply
because we don't give them a good
education there is not another
alternative for what we have to do
so let me ask you let me ask you a
question the you I talked about some
major structural reforms Susan talked
about the need to scale up yeah what
what are the lessons you've learned over
the last several years where you say you
know what this is the thing that makes
the biggest difference this is where we
can we get the most leverage and so if
the federal governments are going to
make an investment is it early childhood
education is it raising teacher pay is
it a matter of increasing accountability
is it after school and summer school
programs so people aren't losing now
I've listed a bunch of things that are
in my education plan actually I know
that play I hope some of them make sense
but but there may be something that that
we haven't thought of what you on the
ground what are you saying that you
think is going to have really Senate
I've read your education policy paper
and I really endorse of the concepts but
this is this is what we found we start
from birth with young people because we
know our kids their parents simply
aren't told what the game is all about
they they we wait until the kids are in
kindergarten first grade and people say
oh educate my child we're middle class
and upper middle class parents start
from the moment of conception they start
living their lives in certain ways
making sure they have good health care
vitamins no drinking no stress our
parents weren't if they no one explained
how this thing goes so we start with
baby college we get those kids and wife
or we put them in our program which
starts at eight o'clock in the morning
goes to 5 45 minute evening it goes for
11 months a year it's very heavily staff
for the last six years a hundred percent
of a not 99 85 every single child into
kindergarten on grade level we know that
you can get those kids on grade level
early if I get a kid was 15 I don't know
maybe he should be reading on the ninth
grade level he could be reading on a
third grade level in one year I may not
be able to catch that kid up but at four
we can catch up every single child in
America every single one of those kids
should be entering kindergarten on great
level and then we have to hold our
schools responsible for making sure
those children never fall behind are one
of the challenges and communities like
Harlem is that we wait until the kids
are so far behind and then we try to
intervene the kids 15 we're trying to
figure out what to do we should still do
that and there are places that have
figured out how to do that kind of work
and we should applaud them and support
them but the real challenge in these
communities is get those children on
grade level early work with their
parents work with the siblings provide
the health care provide that the support
inside the community that make sure
these kids aren't growing up in places
we wouldn't be caught dead because
they're so violent and so disorganized
and then and then you'll have when I
think we found this is very quick my
board chair decided that among other
investments he's made unless he wanted
to start a great chess team in hall he
said Jeff would it be great to have
these Harlem kids beating up on all
these private schools around the country
right so he found the best chess teacher
in America hired that teacher to come
working with my kids in Harlem and for
the last two years our girls ranked
number two and number one in the nation
and chest now this is what people think
no this is not that's not that's not
what that people look at these kids from
harm so hey oh here come the Harlem
girls and he said why are they so good
people say well probably because their
lives are so complicated they have to
move like a rock to get to know that's
not true that's not true they just got
the same advantages that upper middle
class children receive who star chess in
the second and third grade and get great
teaching we are losing so much of our
talent by not doing strategic
investments in these young people early
we will solve all of these other issues
if we educate all America's children not
be so
we've heard some discussion actually
general why don't you go ahead in the
place but I just like to piggyback on
one comment the we talked a lot about
the transformation of the Armed Forces
over the last few years and we usually
talk about it in terms of airplanes and
aircraft carriers and things like that
the biggest transformation of the armed
forces in my career happened in mid
1970s when the Armed Forces insisted
that an educational standard be met as a
precondition to acceptance we went from
the constricted force to the
all-volunteer force and and we held as a
standard about ninety-five percent high
school graduates and so we put value on
that high school degree we made sure
that young kids who want to join the
Armed Forces had a clean record and we
we weren't the the social rehabilitation
project that many court systems made us
become in the early days in my career in
the 1960s in the early 1970s but that
the educational aspect is the biggest
transformational change that happened in
the armed forces of the United States I
say in its history right well and and
and there's there's no industry that's
not impacted by this and and so one of
the things that I want to point out we
talked about getting kids prepared so
that there they start school right there
they're not behind and the problem we
have right now is a bunch of kids are
starting school already behind that the
first day they start and kids aren't
stupid so they figure out pretty quickly
that they're behind and if nobody's
giving them a chance to catch up they
start pulling back and falling further
behind so that's at the earliest stages
but Layla I want to pick up on some of
the work that you've done in terms of
thinking about international
competitiveness one of the challenges we
have is that even those Americans who
get a good high school education we now
know that's not enough
and not everybody is going to go to
Carnegie Mellon or MIT but everybody is
going to need the the capacity to engage
in lifelong learning retraining you know
the notion that we can't guarantee
employment for everybody but we can make
everybody employable in a dynamic
economy requires that they're constantly
being given access to new skills and new
ways of learning how well are we doing
that here in the United States and what
do we need to do to improve how we're
training our workers well I think
Jeffrey is exactly right that we we will
not be a great nation unless we have
great lifetime learning and just as we
need to push downward to the youngest
years as we look out across at countries
that we used to think we're mainly
supplying low-wage low-skill workers to
the world that are now really competing
a world-class manner in high-value
services based on their education system
we are going to have to raise our game
not just K through 12 k through 12 is no
longer the ticket as you were saying to
to employment security it's going to be
K through 14 or K through 16 and for
those workers who move out into the
workforce this is just not our parents
labor market people move more frequently
between jobs than ever before job
tenures have declined and this of all
the rich economies this has the greatest
this economy has the greatest job churn
and the thinnest job training programs
so we need to be looking across the
nation at some of the programs at the
state and local level we need to take
those to scale because there are some
good examples we need to be much better
at consistently funding these programs
if you think about dislocation in this
country if you get dislocated from a job
in America permanently because your
plant shuts down unlike in many
European countries you're not just
losing your income you're learning in
many cases you're losing your pension
you may be losing your health care these
days you may be losing your mortgage and
yet our programs are underfunded to help
those workers dislocated workers on
average go into jobs that pay sixteen
percent less permanently than their
previous jobs so we clearly need to be
focused on these issues like a laser
beam and not just providing programs for
people who are dislocated and unemployed
but helping employers and workers invest
in the skills of their workforce is one
thing we do know looking across
employer-provided training is it skews
very heavily towards the already
educated and skews very heavily towards
the biggest most able corporations and
so the government needs to step in as a
partner at the federal level at the
local and state level to help those
smaller employers and to help employees
at the lower end of the skill level take
control of their own future by investing
in ongoing retooling and reese killing
just a couple of points I want to make
on this one you've got an affordability
issue oftentimes the workers I meet as
you travel around the country they know
they've got to upgrade their skills but
if they're already supporting a family
the idea of them spending two or three
or four thousand dollars to go to a
community college to upgrade their
skills even if they can carve out the
time to do it becomes extraordinarily
difficult so one of the things that
we've talked about is a four thousand
dollar tuition credit every student
every year in exchange for national
service community service of some sort
applying not just to four-year
university students but also those who
may have gone to community college for
two years gone in the workforce for five
want to retrain and you know may just
need a year's course for example to
train for a new job so that's point
number one point number two is working
with our community colleges across the
country and make sure that they are
interacting with
talking to Rick talking to John figuring
out what are the jobs that are actually
going to be there so that they are being
trained for the jobs that exist because
nothing's more heartbreaking than
talking to somebody who took out a bunch
of loans they've got twenty thousand
dollars worth of debt and I'm not
talking about the art history majors of
the political science majors but the
because because we end up going to law
school with it we work out okay but but
people who've been trained in industries
that are already almost obsolete by the
time they've they've gotten out we've
got to make sure that the curriculums
these community colleges are closely
interfacing with with the businesses to
figure out what's a good investment for
these these folks to make Harold we're
talking about a fundamental issue here
of how a service oriented economy shifts
to a knowledge-based economy and this is
not just a problem that requires good
schools and government subsidies for
tuition it also requires those of us who
run academic health centers universities
businesses that have a talk knowledge
debate technological base convince
people that they will have a share in
this new economy that there are jobs
that there are ways that they will
profit and see their lives improved by
moving in this direction to to see a
more science-based and technologically
based and knowledge-based economy be the
dominant force that's clearly happening
in parts of Asia and Europe and we have
to tie into this by bringing together
through perhaps your administration the
forces you're hearing a raid here today
good and you know I don't want to throw
cold water on the education is the
answer but you know only eight in a 30
fastest car jobs in America require a
college education and we've been unable
in the places where we do have jobs
shortages like health care you know to
really build a career ladder so you know
I look at Los Angeles
where we see workers who work in home
care workers who work in nursing homes
or Kaiser who have no mobility between
them and yet we see in New York where
business and unions have gotten together
we've created these kind of aggregated
the trainee not employer by employer but
in a sector you know and now we have
ways to get from a home care worker over
here to be a nurse ten years later and
so you know it all just says to us we
need a plan right this just does not
happen by luck we are making the most
radical transformation you know the
third economic revolution you've only
had three agricultural took 3,000 years
the industrial took 300 years this
revolution could only take 30 years no
single generation of people have ever
witnessed so much change and here you
see all the elements of the change it's
why your plan becomes so important
because it is not going to happen by
everyone doing their own thing I mean
America needs a plan not a communist
five-year plan but more like what
Ireland did you know Ireland got
business and labor and government they
brought them together they created a
framework about taxation and where were
the jobs what were they going to do
about energy policy and they propel
themselves to the second most successful
economy in Europe we are in a moment of
profound changes you talked about in
Flint I don't think Americans quite yet
get it but we need a plan here because
it's not just going to happen as you
listen to everyone around the table
unless we have real leadership you know
that that believes in change you know
and I think that's your challenge well
so it's a good segue
and you make a great point and it's a
good segue for us to move into the third
pillar and that's our health care system
now this is a huge growth area our
population is aging we know that and our
health care system by any standards is
not working well we spend more money per
person on health care than any nation on
earth by a wide margin and yet our
outcomes are mediocre at best when
compared to other industrialized nations
and we've got 47 million people with
without health insurance before gas
prices went up to four bucks the only
thing you'd hear about as you were
traveling around the country is the
extraordinary burden that health care is
being placed now just as is true in
energy healthcare offers an opportunity
given the growth of employment in the
healthcare sector and the work that you
described with SEIU and unions working
with employers you can create systems
where workers have a pathway to good
jobs they are providing an extraordinary
service to an aging population
businesses are reducing costs there's
more money in prevention but that's not
the system we have now know where do we
need a bigger plan than in health care
John I'm going to just start with you
because obviously one of the challenges
for mature industries like steel and the
auto industry has been the legacy of you
know health care programs for retirees
and current workers that put you at a
code huge competitive disadvantage with
with your competitive competitors in
other nations so you want to just talk a
little bit about what kind of help
American business needs and on the
health care front center you put your
finger on it as usual it's an extremely
important matter for us we pay health
care bills for 75 to 80 thousand of our
United States retirees and their
dependents those are promises that were
made by my predecessors but the promises
that we intend to keep but in doing that
as we
pay five hundred million dollars per
year or more in health care benefits
with an accumulated liability of three
billion dollars on our balance sheet
that promise gets more and more
expensive no matter how hard we try with
managed care with wellness with our
employee safety program with company
sponsored clinics no matter how hard we
try our costs go up by ten fifteen
twenty percent per year that promise
become so expensive that it comes out of
our capital it comes out of our
investments now we're still investing
here in Pittsburgh a billion dollars in
the great state of Illinois in Granite
City five hundred million dollars yes
we're very pleased about that and and
we're making those investments so we can
have competitive products to sell to
really good customers like Rick Wagner
but would rather not have to make the
choice senator between honoring our
commitment to our retirees providing a
competitive benefit to our hard-working
employees some of whom you've met that
are at your Thompson plant here there
should be a better choice there should
be a choice that says there's a health
benefit that's competitive affordable
for employers and reasonable for
employees and something that provides a
different kind of health care system
that's based on technology and
information and affordability would be
really welcome for a company like ours
because we want to invest in this system
we have makes it harder and harder for
us to invest and the only thing in our
sector where the fifth largest company
in the world in our sector we're
globally competitive but the only way we
win is by having a smarter harder
working more productive employees which
we have and be investing in the new and
best technology and the health care toll
charge that we continue to pay takes
that investment opportunity away from us
let me just talk about what I've
proposed and then I want to get some
thoughts on people from people like like
most of the Democratic candidates for
president hey my the plan I put forward
focused on not just access but also cost
because if we simply open up a system to
everybody and it's as wildly inefficient
as it is now we'll run out of money
doesn't matter what we do we kick
neither the public sector on Medicare
Medicaid nor the private sector can
sustain ten percent health care
inflation every year or even eight
percent it's just not sustainable so
what I proposed was a system where if
you've got health care we're going to
work with your employer's to lower your
premiums by up to twenty five hundred
dollars per family per year if you don't
have health insurance then we would set
up a system where you could buy into a
pool similar to the one that we have as
members of Congress and that system then
would still have a private market
component but insurers would have to
emphasize prevention emphasized wellness
use technology in all sorts of ways now
this is just one idea there are other
ideas out there Andy you've been looking
at a wide range of reforms and obviously
SEIU has a huge investment both because
a lot of your workers need health care
and aren't getting adequate health care
and a lot of your workers are in the
healthcare industries and you've been
having some interesting conversations
with some unlikely allies including
Walmart which you uh you guys haven't
always gotten along think it's that's
kind yeah so the you're familiar with
what the plans that a lot of Democrats
including myself put put forward their
other proposals that are out there what
what are the bottom lines that you think
have to be accomplished when it comes to
health care right I mean the first
bottom line is we have a health care I
know you talked about a health care
system we really have a health care
sector this is not a system I mean is
you can't talk to each other it be as if
you took ups and divided into ten
thousand package delivery companies and
then tried to communicate and work
together so we need whatever we do we
need to have a system because you can't
take in efficiency out of health care
now because it's to disaggregate is in
too many different places to is I'd say
this is no longer a matter of policy
I've been to more conferences we've had
more meetings there's about leadership
and I think your plan goes exactly to
the play
it's where there's common ground among
business Labour's consumers to build a
system to reduce costs to allow
public-private partnerships to keep the
employer-based system but allow a public
system to compete and I think we need to
do that and I think what we really need
is to just change the old Washington
ways that says we can't get anything
done and that's why after talking to all
of my friends and Democrats and
Republicans in Washington you know I
decided we weren't at a Washington
wasn't going to change so we needed to
change Washington and so I wrote an
op-ed in the Wall Street Journal and
then I wrote a letter to all the fortune
500 CEOs and I said you know the
political class of both parties is full
of words but it's bereft of action and I
said the old idea that business and
labor can't work together for common
good is outdated as lifetime jealous
because we're in a different economy and
to my pleasure so many people have
stepped forward now so we created better
healthcare together Intel AT&T
Communication Workers of America Kelly
service and seiu yes and walmart with a
set of principles very much similar to
the kind of plan you're talking about
AARP the Business Roundtable of National
Federation of Independent businesses
necia you have divided we fail another
coalition where people have come
together our employers and the union in
the partnership for quality care America
is hungry for change in health care the
answers are in front of us and I think
of President Obama can provide the
leadership in the first hundred days to
bring America together and say this is a
competitive plan we can not be the only
nation on earth that puts the price of
health care on the cost of our products
and then convener with countries around
the world that don't it would show
leadership to our business community it
would meet your goal of strengthening
the middle class America needs a new
health care plan and I think America is
ready for it with your leadership stiva
the
you make an important point though and
I've said this repeatedly I don't have
pride of authorship in my furry every
aspect of my plan I mean if other people
have good ideas we want to bring them to
the table the key though is that the
American people have to provide a
mandate for change what in this area I
mean we have to insist that this is not
enough we're going to hold the president
accountable we're going to hold Congress
accountable we can't keep on waiting and
the nice thing is the political
realignment has taken place the last
time we tried this in 1993 frankly the
business community and a large segment
of folks still felt like you know our
system is good enough so we're not going
to put the full weight of our political
clout behind this thing this time you
know I'm expecting us steel and General
Motors and you know other key industries
to say we've got to get this done for
our sake as well and this is number one
on our priority list not not something
that's on the back burner I want to I
want to talk in particular about the
issue of cost on health care because as
I said I think sometimes people are
under the illusion that what we just if
we get everybody covered we're fine and
and and and we can't we've got to make
the system more efficient Steve you've
built an entire business now thinking
about the inefficiencies in the health
care system giving consumers more power
to make good health care decisions talk
to me a little bit about where you think
that we have the most promise when it
comes to prevention wellness and making
better healthcare decisions as a way of
driving down costs well as Andy said we
don't really have a health care system
because the system is highly fragmented
it's not
connected but it's not even health care
it's really sick care we are really in
the business of dealing with people when
they get sick and we already spend two
trillion dollars it's already 16 of our
economy and the cost of you've heard are
going up at a really an unbelievable
rate the only sustainable way to reduce
health care costs is to reduce disease
and the only way to reduce disease is to
get the American people thinking about
and managing their health and their
families health for half a century we've
really trained consumers to kind of
abdicate or outsource health because
somebody else is kind of paying for it
somebody else we're kind of going to
make those decisions and the reality is
we have an unhealthy nation probably
half a trillion dollars we spend relates
to decisions people make eating too much
with obesity or not exercising enough we
have you know way too sedentary
lifestyles or smoking it's gotten better
but still twenty percent of people smoke
those three things alone most people say
account for half a trillion dollars of
our of our spending so we've got to get
people paying attention as not just
consumers or the people asking the
government to get more involved and
provide that mandate it's turning that
back and using the bully pulpit of the
President to really make it clear to
everybody that they have a
responsibility themselves to their
family to their communities and to the
nation to make healthier choices and we
need to create better tools to do that
people have better tools on the internet
for example the track their fantasy
football league than they do the track
their help their families Elvis a
fantasy football is important living a
long healthy productive life perhaps and
more important and so we've done a
disservice to consumers that it's not
really making educating the importance
of making the right decisions giving the
tools to help them make the the right
decision to give them the incentives
including points programs for example
get points if you fly on Air Lines when
you get points you make a healthy
decision so I agree with you that the
core focus really has to be on educating
consumers and empowering them to really
take more control their help and you
have to deal with the cost side of we
simply focus on adding more and more to
the ornaments to the christmas tree the
Christmas tree is going to fall over
we've got
deal with the underlying problem and
it's not a debate about whether the
government pays more employers pay more
or consumers pay more it's really
fundamentally a debate about how we
change the system and really build a
culture of Health and and have everybody
in this country recognize that it's a
civic responsibility to stay healthy
which will therefore reduce disease
which therefore will slow the growth in
health care costs and there's everybody
talks about that every company has some
prevention wellness program or most
companies do but it really needs to be
the centerpiece I would hope if you are
elected it really would become a pirate
for your healthy guy you you know we
ever watches you play basketball and so
that's exactly the kind of message that
we need to carry that everybody they
have to take responsibility this is not
somebody else's problem it's our problem
we're part of the problem we have to be
part of the solution peril I just say
very briefly that I agree with
everything's been said I think we have
to keep in mind that the part of the
issue is equity being sure we provide
health care coverage for everybody
that's just an issue of common sense and
decency and something that Americans
should be proud of secondly we want to
be a leader in the development of new
technologies health care is not going to
be cheap we should control costs but
we're not going to make it as cheap as
it is in some parts of the world and and
the third part is that we want to create
a knowledge-based economy part of that
economy is going to be health care and
health research and one way to make that
a kind of job option for for kids who
are growing up in Harlem and see new
kinds of Technology debase jobs we don't
want those to be jobs in which the
salaries or low we want good salaries
and they're going to be costs and we
need to accept the fact that health is
incredibly important and it will not be
cheap well I think you would distinguish
between the costs of people being
healthier because there is let's say a
new drug that allows them to live a
longer life and a more productive life
we've got an older population so some
costs are actually good value at yes
absolutely then there are the costs of
filing eight different forms in order to
get to the doctor to actual
have that medicine prescribed or there
are the costs related to not providing
reimbursement for a dietitian to help
somebody lose weight but will spend
thirty thousand dollars on a foot
amputation not a cost that is improving
the quality of life and so the key is to
try to figure out how can we accept and
absorb the fact that we've got an aging
population we've got extraordinary
medical breakthroughs some of those will
add additional costs but will be well
worth it because people's lives will be
better versus the costs that are being
born just because we have such a wildly
inefficient system and we are not doing
a good enough job and encouraging people
to make better choices and there is a
reason why the French generally I don't
know whether I don't think it's just the
wine I know they're they're still eating
the foie gras know that are generally
healthier than we are right now and
there they are much happier with their
health care system then then we are it
doesn't mean we have to duplicate their
system what it does mean is is given the
amount of money we spend we should be
getting a lot more out of our system
than we are we're running a little short
on time as I knew we would because we
got a lot of smart people there to other
areas that I want to touch on one we
already started talking about and that's
infrastructure the second is been
pervading the entire conversation that's
the issue of innovation Science and
Technology very briefly what I'd like to
do Federico if you could talk about the
fact that yeah the American Civil
American Society of Civil Engineers gave
our national infrastructure ad and one
of the things that I've noticed is that
we just go about the issue of
infrastructure in a very haphazard way
comment on your experience as a
secretary of transportation and a
secretary of energy in terms of what we
need to do to rebuild our infrastructure
because everybody who comes back on a
visit to China the first thing they say
is boy we are really falling behind
right high-speed
rail highways ports they are essentially
leapfrogging us in terms of their
infrastructure capacity the fact that we
now ranked 15th and/or 20th depending on
in in in in broadband penetration and
speed when Steve who was there at the
inception we invented this stuff how did
we fall so far behind and lael I know
you've you've looked at this as well
let's just talk about for a moment what
we need to do in terms of infrastructure
how do we redesign it so that it's not
this haphazard process that's always a
contest between politics and pork and
but we actually have a systematic way of
thinking about capital investments the
same way that a Rick Wagner or or a John
shirt the sermon do well senator it's
not easy but it requires a completely
different mindset and historically the
way we have funded infrastructure in our
country whether it's highways or transit
system or bridges has been a combination
of state local and federal monies most
even the gas tax both federal gas tax
and state gas tax and that money is
distributed largely through a formula so
that we try to be fair to every state
and as a result of that we continue to
fall behind but more importantly we
haven't addressed the real priority
problems of the country so to ideas of
service number one let's create a new
funding source and you have proposed an
infrastructure Bank 60 billion dollars
which i think is terrific that can be
leveraged either working with the
private sector issuing bonds but
generating new money from a new source
so that we're not so reliant just on a
gas tax which by the way is declining
because fewer people are driving and the
highway users trust us trust fund is
being reduced in in money but secondly
and just as important as finding a new
revenue stream is investing more
strategically so the idea is to look at
the country as a whole and identify the
major roadblocks gridlocks and problems
and most of those frankly are in the
metropolitan communities of our country
if you look at where most delays occur
it's in our metro areas but that's also
where most of the jobs are and where
most of the economic activity in the
country is produced so I think we need
to have a strategic investment set of
criteria that say let's look at these
major roadblocks problems in the country
let's invest in those let's fix those so
that our gridlock our transportation
system works better and lastly we've got
to find a way to connect all the various
forms of transportation in our country
so that we can move people and goods
more efficiently and ensure that we
truly have an integrated national
transportation system so that in brief I
think our at least is a different
paradigm shift and looking at how we
raise the money make more strategic
investments and not just do the same
thing we've done year after year which
frankly is not eliminated congestion
very significantly in our country well
would with that jibe with what you're
saying when you look at what's happening
internationally and it seems as if we're
slipping behind in terms of how we make
infrastructure investments or other
countries making better more strategic
choices in terms of how they're doing
this well absolutely and as you said for
countries like China I mean they're
laying down entire rail systems looking
20 years 30 years out so they are
leapfrogging beyond where we are and it
costs us let me give you a very specific
example China Germany both have invested
a great deal more in their ports the
additional amount of time that you stay
you have to stay in US ports because of
inefficiencies in gridlock and
congestion costs us hundreds of jobs
hundreds of hundred thousand jobs ten
billion dollars worth of exports each
year so for each infrastructure
bottleneck you can actually see that we
are getting
beaten in terms of global supply chains
by our competitors I think what's
interesting is this issue of
infrastructure is critical because it
crosses over competitiveness security
general Jones was talking about that
earlier environmental sustainability and
of course the whole issue of social
opportunity and equity and just by
virtue of crossing across all those
different areas somehow gets no
attention whatsoever and so I think it's
like some of these other issues that
we've been talking about today we need a
plan we need to come to the table at the
federal level with some new tools the
national infrastructure bank that you've
been talking about would be a powerful
new tool and perhaps more important than
anything else we need leadership well
and we're going to have to change our
politics so I mean let's be blunt the
committee chairman really like some of
the prerogatives and the ways of doing
business and I respect that and
understand it if you've got constituents
one of ways that you show that you're
doing a good job is bringing back
projects but if we're not thinking
strategically or systematically at a
national level then we are going to fall
behind because we'll over invest in some
areas and under invest in others and
there's going to be a political fight
around this but now's a great time to do
it look 18 oh that the economy is is you
know I believe in recession we know it's
slowing down at minimum a lot of that
has to do with the decline in the
housing sector you've got tons of
construction workers being laid out that
for us to say let's over the next five
ten years make some significant
investments in infrastructure at a time
when we consumer spending is going to be
declining that will not only make us
more competitive in the long term but
will also stimulate the economy right
now and create jobs that pay good wages
and can't be exported it strikes me as a
perfect recipe for us rebuilding Andy
you want to do governor Sebelius that I
wrote it hop in the Christian Science
Monitor
that said and there's a lot of
discussion going on that if we took a
five percent asset allocation of all the
public pension funds because all these
governors are trying to deal with his
issue as well you know we could raise
about 150 billion dollars almost
immediately we could hire someone to
manage it would be a pooled fund of all
the public sector entities you know
governor Corzine who obviously knows a
little bit about this is very interested
given the problems he's having even
funding the Garden State Parkway and the
turnpike right now so I think there is a
ready source of capital in the public
sector which could be both good
investments for that sector but also
could have a huge amount of capital
quickly to come into the economy hello
let's wrap up with with an issue that's
pervaded the entire conversation that's
the issue of innovation science
technology probably our most important
investment that has to be made and
Harold you know you won the Nobel Prize
you know the first hand the vital
importance of investing in Sciences and
basic research briefly can you describe
what's been happening when it comes to
basic research and basic scientific
investment are we staying at the cutting
edge and if not what what's the solution
in terms of making sure that we thank
you I know I know time is limited we've
discussed some very difficult problems
that we don't really know how to solve
like alternative energy and paying for
health care here's a problem it's a real
problem it's one that drives the entire
economy and we can solve it and we know
the formula it's not even that expensive
right in the last several years we've
had a disastrous decline in funding for
biomedical research we've had
persistence of long-term underfunding of
research in in physical sciences we have
sent signs of discouragement to young
people who would go into Scientific
careers and we have not had a stable
planning process that would allow people
to have confidence in the ability of
this engine that drives the economy to
prosper in the US and we're seeing gains
in other countries with countries we
would like to cooperate with of core
but we also compete with them and we can
solve this by planning of gradual
increases in our science budgets by
having the government received advice
from scientists both within and outside
the government in a open and honest way
so that we return scientist advising to
its historical norm of scientists
providing the facts government making
policy decisions based on economic
reality and the good of the country we
can change all these things that have
undermined the scientific productivity
of the country of the last several years
we're still in the leadership position
in the most of our scientific
enterprises but we're going to lose it
if we don't do some long-range planning
here is a place where Democrats and
Republicans come together when I was the
NIH together the Democrats and
Republicans developed a five-year plan
for increasing NIH support doubling at
over five years that was great but
nobody was willing to think about year
six and the result was that the budget
fell it's been declining in real dollars
ever since and we could have avoided
that with an administration that says
our science and technology development
is crucial to the country we can we can
afford it and we have great talent in
this country we need to encourage it
with a long-range plan a president
arriving in Washington and saying that
research is fundamental to solving the
problems of our country the problems
that go beyond our country's borders and
here is what we're going to do to to set
up a bipartisan agenda for funding
science for supporting the the education
and training that's required for
building an economy that's not just
based on knowledge generated by others
but generated by us would have a
tremendous effect and this is something
that a new president could do tomorrow
Susan I want I want you to help wrap
this up obviously the importance of
science technology engineering math
education is something you think about
it I was just looking at a statistic in
South Korea thirty-eight percent of all
undergraduates receive degrees and
Natural Sciences orange
nearing in Singapore at sixty-seven
percent corresponding number of the
United States fifteen percent and when
you start talking about girls when you
start talking about African Americans or
Hispanics the rates are even worse well
what do we need and Susan oh maybe you
can chime in on this and Geoffrey what
do we need to make science technology
engineering math sexy again for for
students for lack of a better term you
know one of the things that we're seeing
I think if you look at the the
trajectory of engineering for example
you've got baby boomers that were
inspired by the space program and and
that cohort has been supplying a lot of
the brain power for a very long time
there now at a point where they're
thinking about retiring and we're going
to have to regenerate renewed interest
in this area if we're going to stay
competitive any thoughts on this yeah
I've got thoughts but you know they've
been mostly expressed before so Eli and
Susan talked about what the nation needs
and Jeff do you know a huge dose of
aspiration we need to change the
national discussion about what we can do
no one says that learning tough subjects
is easy but anyone who's done it can
tell you it's enormously exciting
tremendously fun and you know people
want to contribute to changing the world
now I've got to say these national data
you just are terrifying the fifteen
percent of our bachelor's degrees the
United States are in science or
engineering this is terrifying mit is
different eighty-five percent of our
undergraduate degrees are in science or
engineering and forty-five percent of
our undergraduates are women so we're
producing lots of women scientists and
engineers but these can't be unique
situations this has to be a situation
that obtains across the nation well and
and is it fair to say that a large
portion of those students are
foreign-born
well it's very interesting a large
portion of eighteen percent of our
students are first in their families to
go to college but among our
undergraduates only eight or ten percent
or international students when you ask
them whether they themselves were born
in the outside the United States or one
of their parents one of their
grandparents what our students represent
is America it's the melting pot you know
85 or 90 percent of our students
probably are immigrants recent
immigrants by those by those measures
and the reason I bring that up because i
actually think we were talking about
this before i want smart kids from all
around the world to study here that's
our crown jewel of competitiveness is
our college and university system and
the fact that we are making it harder
for immigrant students to come your
study and stay is a disastrous policy
but it also though speaks to the
aspirational issue because if our if
children of immigrants still see America
is this land of extraordinary
opportunity and yet we're not producing
that same aspirational culture inside
our country and our schools or at least
in certain areas then that's a problem
so we need you know actually so we
talked about the a 1 2 3 battery company
that maybe the battery for the vote yet
mean Chang is the founder of the company
one of our faculty members just
listening to that name where was he born
not in the United States but we need
teachers who are themselves excited
about math and science and to be excited
by math and science you actually have
got to have studied math and science
yourself they've got to be able to
communicate the excitement and the
importance of power of understanding the
world through that lens you know our
teachers need to be refreshed we can't
train them once and then send them into
the classroom and say that's the end
they ought to re-experience that
exhilaration of learning you know but
you know more than anything else I think
it's this issue of the national
inspiration you touched on it so what we
are now benefiting from is the group of
scientists and engineers who were
inspired by a national mission I grew up
during the race for the moon it was cool
to be interested in science and man we
need another kind of national aspiration
national mission I believe that energy
could serve as a wonderful national
mission it would fuel the innovation
economy economy it would tell kids
around America that they can contribute
to changing the world but you know it's
hard work you gotta study math you gotta
study science you can go into
engineering but you need that kind of
background in order to make a difference
and I believe that kids in America can
be inspired by it mm-hmm absolutely yes
you know and then Eli you'll have the
last word in unbearable remember one
last comment to ask for an energy can be
a source of aspiration but for
aspiration and hope I think we need one
thing at social mobility and the sad
thing is not only has social mobility in
this country being declining we never
measure it we've stopped talking about
stop measuring it's the key to a healthy
capitalist system but and so I hope you
highlight social mobility as a measure
for the next 25 50 years in this country
well I think it's a great point and it
picks up on what end and he was saying
earlier if people see pathways to
success they will succeed if Jeffrey's
kids in Harlem see a road that takes
them someplace they'll take that first
step if those roads look blocked then
they will not and worse they will reject
the opportunities that have made this
country great people always talk about
for example the issue of trade one of
the reasons that I think it's so
important for us to spread the burdens
and benefits of trade broadly and
globalization broadly is so that we can
maintain a consensus of openness and
competitiveness but if you only have a
few winners and a whole lot of losers in
that process over time people become
resistant because they don't see it
adding to the social mobility you're
talking about Elan and then and then
Jeffrey will win additional we've talked
about educational I think we need an
immigration policy that gets the
brightest people from throughout the
world to come here and stay here we had
that several decades ago
you know if I think about it would we
have been better off of sergey brin had
found at Google as a Russian company or
vinod khosla hit da founded Microsystems
is an Indian company we've got to get
back to you type of immigration policy
allow these people to come here and
create great companies and great
industries and I don't have to just say
that there is a sense in this country
that and my belief is anti-intellectual
there there is almost a case to be made
against smart people and that has
penetrated I think from the top
leadership in this country right through
the hood where people look down on folk
who are academically prepared and gifted
and we've got to change that culture and
everyone's gotta you know if the
Americans fascinated by whether or not
you can drink a beer that's not that
should not be the qualification for
president of Resident ought to be able
to lead the nation in a direction where
young people aspire for the kind of
genius that's around this table and not
just drink and do all of it so I think
that there is a chance in poor
communities to get young people inspired
about math and science to believe that
this is really sexy if you want to be
successful if you want then this is the
way to go and we've got to change that
culture in America says the senator one
way we know that we can get kids
inspired about math and sciences when we
make it relevant to their lives and we
know how to deliver instruction that
helps them understand how why they
should care about science and how they
can how it is relevant to their everyday
life this gives me a wonderful
opportunity to mention that this year's
National Teacher of the Year is a
science teacher from Oregon he's a
seventh grade middle school science
teacher Michael geison and that's what
he does he inspires his students to be
very successful in science because he
shows them how it's relevant to their
lives and gets them excited and
passionate about learning science and
that's what we need to do in math and
science oh the look at this has been an
extraordinary conversation and so I just
want to close by thanking everybody who
contributed to the dialogue
you know what I take away from this
discussion is that there is surprising
consensus in this country about what
needs to be done somehow our politics
prevent us from act acting on that
consensus we spend an enormous amount of
time talking about what separates us
along party lines are long racial lines
along economic lines but but when it
comes to how we need to retool America
to continue its greatness we've got a
lot of stuff that we can agree on and
and i think this panel is a testament
because not everybody on here believe it
or not guys are democrats and not i'm
not everybody here i think necessarily
shares a broad political philosophy but
but it shows you how how clear our path
should be and here's what I think we
have to remember though it's not going
to be easy to do we're going to have to
make some choices and we're going to
have to make some changes are we going
to have an economy that's still
constrained by our addiction to oil or
are we going to make a fundamental shift
to grow our economy and secure our
country are we going to let our children
fall behind or are we going to be
satisfied with just some children
learning or we going to say that social
mobility as long as as well as
competitiveness requires every child to
learn are we going to be a second-rate
power when it comes to infrastructure or
are we going to make some investments
that ensure that we stay ahead one of
the central ideas along with upward
mobility and opportunity in the American
Dream is this intergenerational
obligation that this sense that each
generation works and builds and strives
so that the next generation is doing
even better than we are and we do that
in our own families but that's how we've
thought as a nation as well and this is
one of those
that we've got a seat because if we
could get our education system fixed if
we can deal with this issue of energy if
we can revamp our health care system
rebuild our infrastructure and invest
Andrey inspire our young people around
issues of science and technology there's
nothing we can't achieve but if we don't
make those decisions now we are going to
have problems competing over the long
term and that will have not only
economic implications but also national
security implications as well my
intention as president is to bring all
of you back together again along with
others all across this country that are
doing good work to make sure that we are
seizing the moment and achieving the
promise of America and I thank all of
you for what you're already doing I look
forward to working with you over the
next eight years to to see more
improvement